Internet have we counted out Joe Biden
as a candidate too early David F asks is
he counted out because you know because
he's but we know what let me ask this
hypothetical what if like whitewater the
nothing scandal turns into the something
scandal and then it's too late and Jim
the Democrats have nobody else the one
they would turn to it would be Joe even
well I think scandal doesn't turn into
anything the bottom line is that nobody
can consider Hillary inevitable I mean
the idea of inevitability should have
gone out of the window in 2008 when it
was inevitable but then she wasn't
because Obama happened so who knows
what's going to happen yeah I I actually
think Democrats are probably look more
closely at Jim Webb he's a war hero he
especially with national security
probably gonna be looking like a more of
a 2016 big issue than it wasn't what I
think you know he's he's from Virginia
which a blue you know purple state I
think he potentially could be and he's
announced that he's you know really
exploring it so be interesting to see
what happens I find it a little bit
strange that normally some in the press
who you might think would be coming to
Hillary Clinton's rescue right now and
saying some of the things that you said
that maybe the email thing is not such a
big deal have latched on to it and
really taken a grip intentional I am
someone in the liberal media have done
it I don't know where you're getting
this from that the media is liberal the
media could give a [ __ ] about liberal or
conservative with this media loves
scandal and [ __ ] so the idea that
they would ever take a pass on Hillary
Clinton when they could lose I worked in
the media so I'm just telling you
sometimes from the inside these there
are considerations and I'm telling you
from what who watched
you could have a different opinion but
it makes me think that's there are
people out there who are looking for a
different ID and a different plan and
would like to see something else come
along yeah
well I'm one of them what about yours
everybody should be out wanting a real
green ready for Hillary Ariana I'm
actually waiting to see what Hammond can
does Herman came yes there's a
surprising
we are always breaking news here on this
Sherman desk no yeah that's right has
not said I'm deaf right here that that's
waiting yeah so you think the last time
he was just warming up yeah that you
know you sometimes you need one under
your belt like a starter marriage gotta
get what's your starter marriage going
to happen how did this moment happen she
takes it as a personal failure but I
don't have six children now she really
does I'm godmother well and I'm gonna be
the Godfather all right you too what can
you tell us about the legislation you
worked on with Senator Gillibrand well
first of all um well he's done the
military right yeah doing the military
the military justice Act and right now
we're working on a bill about college
sexual assault which would really flip
the incentives for colleges to actually
report crimes and do right by their
students but the interesting thing too
is we have a bipartisan bill which is
you know very rare these days you have
Marco Rubio standing next to Kirsten
Gillibrand Watusi ground which is again
amazing so um a little bit of the
specifics giving the Department of
Education the power to fine making
schools have biannual survey so we
actually have better data so we can
improve policy yeah and also requiring
universities to have a confidential
adviser on campus often times students
have no idea whether options are they
kind of tell them they can't go to the
police who doesn't count they tell them
that they have no rights to actually go
through education procedure it's kind of
like well you should show
talk about it go to the point sometimes
it's a really awful Dean sometimes it's
the professor sometimes it's just a guy
who doesn't want you to out his
fraternity so it's so disappointing you
know there's so many dumb things that go
on on campuses you know I've been
reading instances we're talking about
Sean about political correctness where
they just go nuts like I think it's
Mount Holyoke they won't they don't they
got rid of the Vagina Monologues they
were performing because they said it
wasn't fair to all women because
transgendered women you know what about
women who don't have vaginas they
deserve a mama I mean that kind of crazy
[ __ ] and then they allow actual brutal
rapes that but it just seems so passed
backwards well it's because nothing
happens if a rape happens on campus I
mean and then the worst that could
happen is a department ocation says
never do it again
yeah and well I happen to Florida State
in 2010 and look what happened in 2013
also was really eye-opening and your
movie is that when you were talking
about the Florida State is that Florida
State quarterback Jameis Winston who was
accused of rape he was being defended by
girls too
it's not like there was any solidarity
there they were like you know he's the
quarterback of the football team we got
it we got to get this [ __ ] to shut up I
think that just goes to show you know
you have athletes who are idolized who
are gods walking around as you know 18
19 year-old kids on campus who are in
for it you know by it by the school by
their fans by you know alumni who come
to those games and they're never held
accountable if you're making money for
the school if you're winning football
games and who cares what you do off the
field and so I think we but it's
disappointing that the young girls
themselves who could have been the
victim not on your side it's
disappointing that anybody would do that
I think - okay Cheryl how would you
characterize the relationship between
Obama and the press right now the
relationship is very strained and I
think if you ask is it not with every
president somewhat but I would say more
so and I think that's been expressed
explicitly in letters and interviews by
reporters from the New York Times
Washington Post USA Today Washington
Correspondents Association White House
photographers Association they could
they have said in many different ways
that this is the least transparent and
open administration that they've dealt
with and many of them have been in the
business longer than I have
there's a oh but it's what they care
about I mean to get back to this Hillary
Clinton today she made her comments
about the email scandal she was talking
about women's issues right wasn't that
what the press conference was supposed
to be about she twenty years ago she was
in China saying women's rights are human
rights and human rights are women's
rights and we haven't talked about this
but around the world you what the UN
just released a report that said one in
three women around the world experienced
some sort of violence either sexual
harassment rape violence murder and some
of it codified by the religions in
countries in which they were not one
member of the press asked one question
it was all about email what was on your
server why didn't you use so they don't
care they're not liberal they just want
their just jackals
but your question just have openness I
would say that universally each
administration from my viewpoint I've
only covered three has been worse than
the last in terms of lack of
transparency I feel like the federal
bureaucracy tends to want to covet
information and keep it from us and
that's why the press and others are
supposed to make a balance and this one
is is has picked up and stepped up from
where the last one was I think just a
couple of examples you know the way
they've handled whistleblowers and also
what's happening with detention centers
there are 200 immigration detention
centers in America which have become
like gulags you can't get information
families can't get information and this
administration has deported more
immigrants than Bush so you know there's
a lot wrong and and so the the fact that
they didn't ask Hillary the right
questions doesn't justify what the Obama
administration is doing when it comes to
transparency okay what does it mean that
Boko Haram is joining Isis oh yes Boko
Haram a couple of days ago told Isis
they they want to get hitched
and Isis thought it over and the wedding
is going to take place now they're gonna
it's like a bachelor I had a really very
romantic is this kind of coalition
building making them more dangerous well
yeah of course I had a piece in this
earlier this week and the problem that
you have is the leader of Boko Haram in
Nigeria sky called Abubakar Shekau who
is basically a psychopath and and I
don't use that as a kind of flippant
line one of the things Boko Haram is
known for is leveling villages but they
also like to go to student dormitories
lock the kids in there set it on fire
any kids who escape through windows then
get caught by them they'll slit their
throats so it's the counterpoint to Isis
the problem is they were joining it's
about the metastasis of Salafi jihadi
ISM which is the particular brand of
Islam they both subscribe to and the
Islamic state the kind of narrative that
it's being able to survive and that it's
expanding is deeply appealing on but it
gives it's violent extremism just
now Islam involved with math but you
could literally uncomfortable about that
but it's Salafi jihad is emits a
specific you could look at yeah and out
believe me I know all right thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen